ils sont là tout comme de bon nombre de
partis politiques
les jeunes sont sur tous les fronts
l'université d'été rassemblements
manifestations et cela depuis bien
longtemps
exemple ici en 1975 à la fête de l'huma
c'est pas seulement une fête pour
s'amuser mais c'est une fête politique
pour amener les gens qui n'ont pas
compris à prendre conscience des
réalités
nous sommes ici pour leur donner des
explications et l'on y tenons à leur
disposition et pour que l'explication
soient claires et percutante rien de tel
qu'une petite formation 1975 toujours et
jeunes giscardiens apprenait à faire de
la politique grâce au coaching vidéo
c'est corrigé après l'exercice de
dialectique dans la salle de critiques
attentiste lempire soissons le
secrétaire d'état aux universités et
henri giscard d'estaing le fils du
président de la république vous employer
le langage des français et la vie de
tous les jours si vous voulez compris il
faut convaincre et parler un langage
très ça la jeunesse vitrine des partis
politiques
une recette qui fonctionne toujours
aujourd'hui sur terrain le discours est
bien rodé et les jeunes vrp savent
défendre leur leader au niveau du
pouvoir d'achat si l'europe fait
progresser le pouvoir d'alors justement
le jeu vient faire le bien si vous me
laissez parler je vous le dis bayonne
règlement et c'est moi parler je vous le
dis je vous ai par exemple nicolas
sarkozy va sûrement être le premier
opéra tva à 5,5 sur la restauration
passe il obtient certains partis
politiques nist aussi sur cette nouvelle
génération pour rajeunir leur image
voilà donc les gars de la marine comme
il se surnomme un bataillon de
moussaillons de moins de 30 ans qui
s'emploie face aux caméras à casser
l'image une forme qu'on lui prête
les jeunes sont aussi bien utile aux
parties pour leur maîtrise de la
communication numérique et l'art
omniprésence sur les réseaux sociaux
notamment lors des campagnes électorales
la force et le changement de ses qg 2012
ce sont peut-être les équipes numérique
au ps une fourmilière de 50 jeunes
s'activent pour animer la planète web
dont le fils du candidat thomas hollande
et le parti des manuels macro est lui
aussi porté par la jeunesse un outil de
communication définitivement
incontournable
[Musique]
oh